the Joe Rogan experience where you're
like but it's not that because you don't
can't think about that because if you
think about that it's time that takes
away from the actual thing the actual
thing deserves a hundred percent of your
attention and the acts I'm not saying
you feel that in the moment but when do
you [ __ ] feel it like when you're
like good night and everybody explained
that it go it's go get it cut me out
here then I start thinking okay hey cuz
that's how I go that's how that's what
makes me go that what makes me go is the
thing I can't always concentrating on
the thing like I do I get the thing that
you don't worry alright so I
concentrated on the thing but like then
if I can celebrate that like holy [ __ ] I
stuck the landing well I do that with my
friends right after the show like we we
have a great show like me and Santino
Saturday night we have this [ __ ] wild
show there's a Rina in Cleveland it was
awesome after it was over we high-five
we get something to eat and that's it
then then you let it go you got to let
it go because that my thinking is you're
talking on the road every night and it's
like even though like it's a different
show every night and it's different
wonderful audience like I'm still
thinking about the two shows we had the
music box and the Chicago theater like
how my god it was religious of all the
screenings I've ever had in my life like
those two will stick out think it's
different too because you're playing a
movie that you did you're putting out a
piece and you get to sit down and watch
people enjoy the piece and you get to
get this like big rush yeah but the cute
thing
the Q&A is also organic you know
yourself definitely being yourself but
it's organic as you want it to be yeah
like basically somebody asks you a
question you're like right here's a long
answer or maybe had nothing to do with
that question right but even then it's
like that it's not like you're doing us
like a bit you know like where you have
to begin your set thank you very much
cago great to be here here's the thing
about Chicago you have memorized bits
oh yeah there's bits but they don't I
was always blown away by Carlin like one
day we were rehearsing on Dogma and
George Carlin was
anyway a smoke break it was the 90s
everybody smoked cigarettes and [ __ ] and
I was like what do you what are you
working on now George when you're not
doing this and everybody was the
nurse'll Matt Ben Linda Salma Chris Rock
go [ __ ] cast me Jay and George is
like I'm working on this bit for the new
HBO show he goes called advertising
lullaby and I said what do you mean
working on it and he goes well
memorizing it and I was like you
memorize your bits and goes yeah I write
everything I was like you write your
bits I was just like he kind of came up
with [ __ ] off top your head it goes nuts
he's like I write everything and then I
have to memorize everything like a
script and then we were like can you do
it and he's like yeah you want to say it
and so he did a command performance for
the eight of us in the room of
advertising wallah boy and it was pitch
perfect I saw the HBO show like you know
months later and it was pitch perfect so
I couldn't believe that that dude was as
committed to the written word as he was
but he fancied himself a writer first
and foremost he's got time and want to
do comedy though like he really backed
into it he was he wanted to be Danny
Kaye he wanted to act and stuff like
that and he was just happen to be funny
first he did the radio DJ thing and then
the hippie dippie weatherman Burns and
Allen was prior to that and stuff but he
kind of backed into comedy and was
excellent at it yeah but was not like it
was not like this is what I've always
wanted to do since I was a kid just kind
of he always seemed to accept the fact
that he was like oh I'm this is it I'm a
genius at this all right well he did it
differently he would do I mean he was
probably the most prolific big-name guy
of all time and he he actually inspired
louis c.k to do a new hour every year
because that's what he did
Carlin George did a new hour every year
and part of the reason 175 nights a year
that's crazy but part of the reason why
is he owed a lot of money did a big time
yeah I don't know how that happened but
in his book last words he talks about
like he bought a jet and sometimes he
bought a jet he in the 70s he was that
[ __ ] huge he bought a jet and he
would sit on the runway in Long Island
at a at a [ __ ]
LaGuardia yeah and just do coke and the
[ __ ] price this is his book last
words as a
amazing Wow they published it
posthumously but he was working on it
with Tony Hendra before he died he was
so awesome man like I think about him
all the time
anytime I jump on stage because we every
night after reboot we get up on stage
and work the crowd and stuff I got a
chance to say hello to him once though
that's it what would ya yeah I met him
at the Comedy Store it's very friendly
said hi to everybody said hard the door
guys hey Howard hi to me hey George how
are you didn't know who the [ __ ] I was
had no idea just said hi I said hey man
how you doing that's it that was our
thing I have a I mean I worked with him
a few times in the movies and stuff he
one of my favorite [ __ ] memories of
George Carlin is we go see him do a show
me and Chris rockers me and my wife Jen
and Chris was married to his wife a lock
at that point and George is playing at
Caesars in Atlantic City and so he's
like I got seats for you guys up front
and stuff so you know Rock was like had
his roll with the new he was like [ __ ]
at the height of his game and [ __ ] and
so we go see the show and Karlin had a
bit where he it was like people I could
do without like guys named skip [ __ ]
like that mm-hmm
and one of them was people I could do
without any man over the age of 12 who
wears their baseball cap backwards so
you know long before I met him I'd
always hear that get that bit be like uh
so the night we're at the show he's up
there doing it bit and and you know he's
like another person I could do without
Kevin you're exempt from this guy's over
the age of 12 where their baseball cap
backwards and rock like my eyes lit up
and rocks next to me and rock goes he
knows who you are even though like we'd
work together on the movie it was so you
exempt though for the for the show
there's that kind of school he was a he
I think we got along because he he
wanted to act and I was always like come
act come play and like he leave like in
Jay and Silent Bob strike back he plays
a hitchhiker that like blows people for
rides right
the day he was such a committed actor
the day we shot we had him for a few
hours and then he had to rush off to go
be on a stage and be Carlin
so he made a little winded window of
time for us and he came to me on set and
he goes uh Kevin you're the writer
director of this I have a question for
you I was like okay and he goes uh you
know this says that I'm [ __ ] with
these dudes I talked to him about the
rules of the road am I [ __ ] with these
idiots or do I believe in the rules of
the road and I was like wow I can't
believe you're giving it this much
[ __ ] thought George I said but like I
the way I wrote it I assume the guy
believed in the rules of the road and he
goes that's what I thought I was that's
exactly what I [ __ ] thought he was so
like committed to performance man like
he was an absolute joy to be around and
he was never on he's like you like
[ __ ] not like a man I bet them
doughnuts he doesn't feel the needs make
your left I love Tracy Morgan to death
don't get me wrong but like you gotta
save six hours for facial you know cramp
rehabilitation yes because you're just
laughing so are you're laughing in your
faces and that rictus grin the entire
[ __ ] teen you ever made John
Witherspoon is he the same way oh my god
I did a show with John Witherspoon and
his son JD and my [ __ ] face hurt
after it was over it was like Chris us
Morgan like my cheeks were hurting
George was not that guy he just sat
there and have a conversation with him
like he was just interesting you don't
mr. Hackl
dunno miss Pat do you know who she is
she's another one she make you [ __ ]
face her really oh my god she's so funny
and her stories are so crazy she has you
listen real yeah what were your dreams
well
kinnison was my boy that's why I got a
long coat first trench coat yeah well I
was introduced to comedy through my
parents having Cheech and Chong album ah
Cheech and Chong Tommy Chong is in Jay
and Silent Bob reboot and then Bill
Cosby and then when I was that gave me a
Bill Cosby albums and my mom would
always be like you can't listen George
Carlin but you can listen Bill Cosby
[Applause]